e naquele tempo eu tentava lhe mostrar
muito tipo um um artista nada mais é do
que o ser humano normal é porque
realmente a individualidade de cada um
faz as pessoas serem muito especiais
entendeu Tipo assim querendo ou não tipo
Tu tem a fala presa né a língua presa e
querendo ou não tipo hoje tem a pessoa
que tem a língua presa que mais tem
audiência EA galera tipo nem fica
falando sobre isso tu tá entendendo tipo
assim é uma coisa única e é uma parada
que é só tu que tem porque talvez outra
pessoa a galera ia falar se eu não
assistam porque a voz dele fala aquilo
só que como é você e do jeito que você é
do jeito que você faz é um jeito único
Zinho que pega que pega uns 20 e tantos
milhões de pessoas pelo Brasil